كيف قرات هجوم القسام في جحر الديك وتلك
المشاهد التي بثت لهذا
الهجوم حسن خصائص هذه الحرب مختلفه يعني
لنتحدث عن المثلث جباليا الشجاعيه
والزيتون هناك تنصب الكمائن يعني في جحر
الديك هناك عمليه الاغاره يعني كما يقال
هت اندران او اضرب واهرب هذه المنطقه هي
المنطقه الخاصره الطريه ان كان لقطاع غزه
منها تم الدخول في المرحله الاولى في هذه
المرحله تكررت العمليات يعني با 2 ديسمبر
الماضي شهدنا ايضا عمليه خاصه عندما طوقت
المقاومه ب عبوات ناسفه مجموعه من الجنود
60 جندي وفجرتها فاذا هذا هو الاغاره بعكس
ما يحدث في المناطق ذات يعني الاشتباك كات
الحاده مثل الشجاعيه و حسن قد قد تؤثر ق
قد تؤشر هذه المنطقه حسن الى المرحله
القادمه التي تحدث عنها الامريكي في حال
حصلت وانتقلت اسرائيل من
القتال ذات هاي انتني كونفلكت كما يقال
يعني قتال ذات حده عاليه الى قتال ذات
حده منخفضه هذه العمليات هي احدى العمليات
اليوم الاهداف كثيره ثلاثه فرق تهاجم غزه
شمالا وسطا وجنوبا الاهداف الاسرائيليه
متوفره اين تجد المقاومه هدفا معينا تذهب
تضربه وهنا تضرب خلفيه العدو او ما يسمى
بالانجليزيه حسن لاين اوف كومينيكيشن او
خطوط المواصلات الخطوط الخلفيه اشرت الى
ان جحر الديك تعتبر من المناطق الرخوه هي
من المناطق الاولى التي توغلت فيها قوات
الاحتلال هي مناطق زراعيه وبالتالي ليست
فيها ابنيه كثيره ووا ضح من خلال صور
الهجوم
ان مقاتلي القسام كانوا في منطقه مكشوفه
ليس فيها الا بعض الكثبان الرمليه ورغم
ذلك تمكنوا من الاجهاز على جنود قوات
الاحتلال كيف يمكن ان تفسر ذلك بوجود
مراقبه جويه او من المفترض ان تكون هناك
مراقبه جويه على مدار
الساعه لنكن واقعيين حسن لا يمكن ان يكون
هناك مراقبه
جويه 100% ومفعول ومفاعيل مهمه 100% اليوم
الاولويه بالنسبه لجيش الاحتلال هي مثلثه
الشجاعيه جباليه والزيتون وحتى التفاح
وحتى جنوب يعني جنوب القطاع اليوم عندما
تكون قادر على الاستطلاع على تقيييم
المعلومات على الاستلام التكت عن العدو
وبالتالي ضربه في مكان حيث لا يكون متهيا
لهذا الامر هذا يدل ان عمليه القياده
والسيطره واختيار الاهداف هي عمليه سليمه
ولا تزال قادره المقاومه على اجراء هذا
الموضوع يعني عدم القدره على القياده
والسيطره وتنفيذ العمليات هذا امر يعني
انها تراجعت قتاليا هذا الامر ليس
بالضروره ان تكون في مناطق مكشوفه قد يكون
هناك مناطق مكشوفه يعني جحر الديك قال
صهيب 4 خ م حسب المعلومات هي 13 كم مربع ا
4000 نسمه ليس فيم فيها اماكن سكنيه بل
يمكن ان يكون هناك مقاتلين من المقاومه
ويمكن ان يكون هناك الانفاق ولكن تكرار
هذه العمليه يعطي امر معين انه الجيش وكيف
يتصرف ط الحديث بالحديث عن الانفاق هنا
وبالانتقال الى الشجاعيه التي شهدت ايضا
العديد من الهجمات التي قامت بها كتائب
القسام وغيرها من
الفصائل هناك مشاهد بثت ايضا للجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول في الشج ج عيه استهدفت
مقاتلا من حماس يقول داخل نفق وتبعنا هذه
المشاهد ايضا على الهواء كذلك ما الذي
قرات في مشاهد جيش
الاحتلال ا انا لم اشاهد النفق حسن ولكن
بالتحليل المنطقي والعماني هذا التقدم هي
تقول انها كشفت حتى الان اكثر من 800 فتحه
لهذه الانفاق ولا تزال الانفاق تعمل هل هي
فعلا تعرف ما هي الانفاق اليوم عندما
نتحدث عن الشجاعيه انتقلنا الى مرحله
مختلفه هذه المرحله وهذا بتصريح اسرائيلي
اساسي في هكذا عمليه ايه الشيء الغير
معتاد حسن هو ايه العديد اللازم ويجب ان
يكون عديدا كبيرا للقتال اثنين الوقت الذي
ي يستلزم لانهاء المهمه وهذا وقت طويل
بدانا بالشهر الثالث
والذخيره الاستهلاك الذخيره الكبير وهذا
الامر يدل سعي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لارسال مزيد من قضائ الميركافا وبالتالي
عدد الضحايا وهذا ما نشاهده يوميا اليوم
ان تقول انك كشفت فتحه لنفق معين في
الشجاعيه وهذا يعتبر انتصار انا لا اعتقد
ان هو الانتصار الكامل من هنا عدم قدره
اسرائيل على قياس هذا النجاح ان كان في
شجاع خان يونس وحتى في جحر الديك شكرا لك
الياس حناء الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
حدثنا من جبل لبنان